[Music]
thank you
today reviewing the Nvidia RTX 3090 TI
2200 gets you this and it also gets you
one of these we're at that at that stage
now we got the octopus cables going on
three eight pins for this one feeding
into a single 12 pin we're gonna have a
full tear down obviously but in this
video we're focusing on the performance
to some extent the value and we'll also
be going over extensively The Thermals
and the design characteristics how it
performs overall but the prices what you
need to know right away the cheapest
ones of these we're aware of start at
two thousand dollars
let's get started before that this video
is brought to you by Kale mods pcie 4.0
Riser cables available in 90 degree and
straight connections the pcie Gen 4
Riser cables run up to 30 centimeters
long and pair well with cable mods
vertical GPU brackets designed to
maintain a more optimal distance between
the video card fans and the case side
panel kill mod markets that these have
full speed signal transmission because
they use a Pure copper tinning process
to achieve better signal quality learn
more at the link in the description
below the money angle is pretty known at
this point for these cars we've done
we've done the gag before now it's more
of a power thing though the 3090 TI
is the most power hungry card we've
tested before overclocking so we'll go
over the numbers in a little bit in
detail but you're looking at 500 watts
plus or minus maybe 20 here doesn't help
you a lot uh for the 3090 TI and that is
drastically increased over the original
30 90. what that extra power gets you
we're going to save everyone the time
here and just give you the quick version
up front is somewhere between about
eight and twelve percent on average
uplift over an RTX 3090 non-ti which we
have been calling the business casual
edition of the 3090 or the filthy pores
edition if you will because the 390s
high does the business person's 30 90.
so the ti is a 10 752 Cuda core card
versus the 3090 original card that's at
ten thousand four hundred and Ninety Six
Cuda core is not a big difference there
a couple percent uh it's a non-linear
increase in performance for Cuda core
increases because there are other
factors that play too like bass and
boost clocks uh rops tmus uh the memory
bus the memory controllers the amount of
memory all that stuff factors in but
that's the change just for the GPU core
uh and the Cuda core account within it
so anyway the pricing was mostly hidden
up until the last minute for this one
the whole launch was actually pretty
pretty last minute from Nvidia where the
card showed up on Friday for us we
started testing immediately the review
goes up now and so that means we had
basically all of Saturday Sunday to
produce it and Monday to produce it turn
it around pretty well came out as we
like it but our Focus here is going to
be on thermal and power first and
foremost because the one thing this has
going for it within the pricing spectrum
is that it's a flagship Ultra high-end
card so everyone expects that the value
is going to be bad that's just how it
works
from that angle there's still some fun
to be had for this being an Enthusiast
card which is why we're doing all the
overclocking with it and the focus on
things like power consumption uh
additional things you need to know 24
gigabytes of dddr6x memory it's a
384-bit bus and then for the die it's
ga-102-350 for the Silicon with the TDP
F450 I don't know I put this many in
there they kept coming out for the rest
nvidia's marketing is largely focused on
8K well largely it's about it's about 30
8K gaming so they've backed off a little
bit from the mockery of the 3090 or
Nvidia torpedoed its own launch on that
one by focusing on 8K gaming as if
that's a thing anyone gives a about
but it's also talking about being a
Creator card we actually don't disagree
with this aspect because the 24
gigabytes of memory is extremely helpful
for our workloads and working on what
now everyone calls content creation so
we use Unreal Engine 5 for example we
use it for visualizing our office we use
it for building out animations these
days largely replaced blenders rendering
with real time rendering an Unreal
Engine and the memory does help there we
use 3090s for that so we can see the
value we get it for most people of
course these flagships should be in a
way considered to be Titans they should
probably rename so that Nvidia doesn't
bear the expectation of being a gaming
card that is granted by an on Titan card
but they should be thought of the same
way now ultimately this value is
atrocious it's terrible value versus a
30 90. there's the same memory capacity
you don't gain much 8 to 12 like you
said and really the takeaway is that the
memory moves all to one side of the PCB
that's the value here so there's not a
lot of value outside of that it's easier
to cool and that's kind of it anyway
let's get started with the benchmarks we
have a lot to talk about for testing and
then we'll go through a little bit more
of the conclusion but you've basically
gotten it here already power consumption
testing is up first we're front loading
this because the card is so impressively
power hungry that this test has actually
become really interesting we have no
doubt that transient load survival is
going to be one of the hardest tasks for
power supply to keep up with with a 39
DTI but that's harder to test in a short
review window in the very least we can
start with raw power consumption in a
torture workload the total card power
draw of the RTX 3090 TI ftw3 was a
shocking 500 watts running two of these
with anything else on the computer at
all would put you into dual power supply
territory on a 115 volt wall drop so
we're truly backed in the era of ultra
high power draw components the GTX 480s
would be proud of this one it's like
true to form for older style Nvidia now
the big difference now versus then is
that cooling has become far more
advanced but mostly at the cost of form
factor that's why this card is so fat
the ocv BIOS pulled the same 504 Watts
as it only adjusts for fan speed the
power consumption versus the stock 3090
non-ti also ftw3 previously at 389 watts
is 29 higher with a 30 90 TI ftw3 that's
going to set the tone for this entire
review because it sets the tone for
efficiency or the percent Improvement
for the percent increase in power drop
overclocking the 3090 TI got it up to
533 watts in line with the seven percent
power Target offset but take a look at
this chart the per rail power
consumption looks like this during the
overclocked testing the total power
consumption maximally spiked to 560
Watts but it may have spiked even higher
if they're in a microbursted transients
which typically are up to about 100
microseconds in length we can only
measure 100 milliseconds with this
particular equipment although we're
working on that but the sudden drops and
the total power consumption seen in this
chart are from stability of the
overclock it's actually somewhat
difficult to stabilize this card under
some conditions like torture workloads
but more on that later in our
overclocking section the pcie cables
fairly universally ran at about 108
watts each we'll plot them one by one
here that makes sense because they all
feed into the same single 12 pin
connector ultimately the pcie slot is
capped at 66 Watts at 12 volts and 75
Watts total for the spec and we're well
under those numbers here the card is
primarily leaning on the cables which is
sensible when there are three available
I'll plug it into an octopus but the
slot draw was 10 watts on 12 volts and
about zero Watts on 3 volts our thermal
testing is extensive on this one but
we'll split it into two charts and we'll
start with the simplest one equilibrium
temperatures for the GPU core GPU
hotspot and memory tested across all 3v
bios options is what we're looking at
first the V bios is on this card only
adjust fan speed not the power limit
which is capped at 480 Watts so we'll
look at that next in the slower RPM
normal V bios the card ran well within
acceptable tolerance is at 70 degrees
Celsius core and 79 degrees on the hot
spot with ambient temperature at 20
degrees Celsius but this is not delta T
over m is just the temperature of the
card at 20c for ambient the memory
thermal has averaged at 71 degrees for
this V bios the performance V bios is
the default EVGA choice though and this
one had us at 63 degrees 71 degrees for
a hot spot and 64 degrees for memory the
OCB bios has no meaningful impact on
anything in our testing and doesn't even
look like it's changed anything here the
chart we're showing now is for an AMD
CPU actually but it's helpful to
illustrate this next Point as a reminder
GPU thermals directly impacts boosting
frequency every couple degrees Celsius
can be the difference of maybe 12 or 15
megahertz on the clock for most cars but
these really fat high-end cards can
normally Flatline the frequency the
Nvidia behavior is more nuanced than
what we saw on that AMD charge but
modern AMD CPUs behave in a similar
fashion by leveraging additional thermal
Headroom to boost higher here's the
frequency chart for the 39 DTI the
normal vbios has us at about 20 25
megahertz dead for most of the test
although it peaked at 20 40 megahertz at
the start proving the point on how a
couple degrees results in that 15
megahertz reduction we saw the
performance of BIOS runs a slightly
higher clock at 2040 for the full test
that's not for any reason though other
than the more aggressive fan curve
programmed into V bios for the ocv BIOS
without any overclock actually applied
frequency starts at about 20 55
megahertz but settles at the same 2040
as performance the flat line is somewhat
remarkable here Nvidia Fe cards
typically have much more chaotic
frequency plots as do lower end board
versions for almost any GPU that's
because they're more power limited for
the Target here EVGA has boosted its
power Target enough that the common
limiter is V Rel or voltage not power if
you were to boost voltage externally or
through a mod the calf would become
power or thermal instead so v-rel or
voltage is the reason we're stuck at
this flat line but the flat Line's a
good thing fan speed is the next most
important part seen as it's the only
thing that changes with these V buyers
options the normal V bios has us at zero
RPM and boosts to about 1657 RPM over
sustained load hysteresis has us at
about 383 seconds required to stabilize
the fan RPM against the V bios
temperature Target the performance fee
bios jumps nearly immediately to 1980 to
2000 RPM under the same test conditions
hysteresis or fan ramp lag is closer to
just 200 seconds to ramp but the jump
from 0 to 1800 takes place in about two
seconds that's very noticeable to the
end user and will be more audible than
the curved ramp of the normal V bios
which only instantaneously jumps to
about 1200 RPM the ocv BIOS doesn't seem
to do anything different than
performance V bios but remains useful as
a switch for flashing haxby bios is onto
later like for xoc so the main takeaway
here is that you can run this card sized
such that it is at a much lower RPM of
about 200 to 400 RPM reduced off of the
automatic speeds we're seeing and still
be within an acceptable thermal
tolerance and what that allows you to do
obviously is just have sort of a better
user experience without really giving up
very much it's still well with an
acceptable range the frequency doesn't
change much more than 15 25 megahertz
Max and that's kind of what our
recommendation would be if you were to
buy one of these cards uh or really if
you buy anything that is sized like this
on a lower end card as well the other
takeaway is the opposite end there's
room to ramp the fan speed and there's
room to leverage the thermal
capabilities of the cooler for a bigger
overclock but if you're going to do that
really you need an unlocked to be bios
where the power Target is uncapped or at
least capped higher right now it's
capped at uh well about 480 Watts stock
and you do seven percent offset and that
kind of limits you so we're seeing Max
500 530 Watts somewhere in there for
total board power and that's just not
enough to get really much more out of it
so you would need a mod for that to go
further and finally this is at least
showing that this cooler is attached two
of the components and cooling them
properly we've seen other massive cards
in the past like the Zotac 1080 TI where
it has this huge cooler but it's not
really connected to anything except the
GPU sometimes so it is at least being
leveraged here now for the memory and
voltage regulator module thermals this
is where things have historically Fallen
apart for the non-ti 3090 cards due to
low heat sinking capability of the back
of the PCB for this one using the
hottest V bios as a measuring stick the
tested memory modules that never
exceeded 67 degrees Celsius on the NTC
thermistor logging the data this is well
within spec and as a relief as compared
to the original RTX 3090s although the
price is Extreme the vrm components
never exceeded 65 degrees Celsius during
testing which is also well within spec
these could scale up to 100 degrees
Celsius and still technically would be
within spec so there's a lot of Headroom
here EVGA has built an insanely Overkill
cooler for an insanely Overkill rights
okay next we're going to talk about
overclock performance and stepping the
really important thing we want to lay
out here is that as you're overclocking
you have to do validation so it's not
good enough anymore to just run it with
the core offset the memory offset and do
that until it crashes now once you think
it's running stable you also need to do
a performance check with something like
Port Royal or a game that's repeatable
anything that gives you a repeatable
score because if that's not done then
what can happen is silent memory errors
in the background that would actually
produce a lower result than stock we've
seen that it's possible to think you've
overclocked your card but actually
you've just heard performance worse than
stock because it's not crashing so it
doesn't present the catastrophic failure
but it also is silently failing each
application will behave differently here
so you want to tune for sort of the most
fussy of all of them and then for
frequency offset and power percent
remember that these are always relative
to what the the card is doing anyway so
if one card has 115 power Target the
other one's 107 it doesn't mean that 115
is higher than 107 other than that has
true numerical value because if the
power of one is 480 watts and the power
of the other one is 450 Watts obviously
the percentage means a different thing
here's the step in when using Port Royal
to validate we had already determined
that 125 megahertz offset was the most
reliable for wide reaching stability in
various games so we settled there
although it sometimes could hold 160
megahertz offset and Times by extreme
that would not hold globally and
especially not in games so it's not
really valid because it wasn't stable
first off we noticed that the EVGA
Precision voltage slider actually does
something here The Slider helps
stabilize the maximum frequency without
any other changes and you can see that
when our limiter switches from v-rail to
power the frequency jumped up by 15
megahertz just by moving that slider and
changing nothing else which also allowed
an immediate jump in score for about 15
480 or 15 490 maximally to about 15 500
20. that's an increase of about 0.25
percent and if you've seen our extreme
overclocking streams that's actually a
pretty big jump for just doing one
slider from zero to Max this slider only
tells the voltage to run its peak
available option consistently so it can
be thought of more as a binary switch
than an actual voltage offset is not
offsetting voltage by 100 units of
anything it's just kind of fully offset
to the peak or not from the stock 14 880
results on normal V bios up to the max
15 549 score we got with our heavier OC
we got about a four and a half percent
uplift overall there's about two hours
of work to get this stable and
operational we'd say that this generally
isn't worth overclocking today but we've
seen cards in the past like the 1080 TI
or the 780 Ti or 980 TI where
overclocking becomes disproportionately
valuable as the card agents we don't
know if that'll be true here though in
other words 4.5 today in today's
applications may turn into 7 or 10 in
the future either way the overclocking
aspect is clearly more fun from an
Enthusiast tinkering standpoint than it
is from a practical one at four and a
half percent in Shadow of the Tomb
Raider at 4K the RTX 3090 TI ftw3 stock
card ran at 119 FPS average leading the
original 3090 ftw3 by about 12 percent
that's with brand new data too we we ran
another 3090 and got about the same
averages as we did previously the end
result is two and a half percent more
power consumption for about every one
percent more performance showing that
we're beyond the operating point for
efficiency overclocking the 390 TI
certainly doesn't help that argument but
it did boost the results by a five
percent average FPS while maintaining
good low FPS consistency the 6900 XT it
runs at about 98 FPS average here that's
too bad because the human eye can only
see above 100 FPS so this card is best
left to the pores and The Peasants the
lead over the 6900 XT is about 21 at 4K
okay in this game though this would
reduce as we approach lower resolutions
but there's obviously a limit to how low
of a resolution you'll go with with
these cards at 1440p the results have
the RTX 3090 TI ftw3 at 176 FPS average
with lows still in good shape for
overall frame time consistency that has
the 3090 tie leading the 3090 ftw3
non-ti by 3.7 percent in exchange for 15
more money comparing ftw3 to ftw3 the
6900 XT encroaches here but we're
predictably limited by the CPU in this
set of data as well clearly in terms of
value you really shouldn't be buying
either of these cards for gaming that's
not news we've been saying that they
don't make any sense for the vast
majority of use cases the 3080 or the
6800 XT achieve most of the performance
for a fraction of the price even
factoring in scalp's prices this isn't
news to Nvidia either they're trying to
distance themselves from the gaming
marketing for these cards because it
worked out very poorly last time when
they tried to make it a whole big 8K
gaming thing anyway these are more
worthwhile if you need the vram like we
do for some of our blender and Unreal
Engine workflows but because Nvidia
shipped these out with sort of two days
of notice there wasn't a whole lot of
time to factor that in Total War 3
Kingdoms is run at ultra settings in our
test Suite which makes it one of the
most abusive Benchmark scenarios that we
run the RTX 3090 Thai stock card plotted
at about 60 FPS average at 4K which
gives it a 10 lead over the RTX 3090
business casual ftw3 the overclock
pushes another three FPS average not
noticeable to a human at this level but
probably noticeable to whatever this is
the lead over the RTX 3080 is about 26
percent with a 6900xc roughly in the
same spot ultra settings at 4K are
ridiculous though you could easily make
this playable and enjoyable at 4K with
these cards by dropping settings one run
we leave them high for the value of
creating a strain and for showing
scaling though at 1440p the 3090 TI ftw3
ran at 116 FPS average still constrained
by the game more than the CPU and the
ram the lead remains about eight percent
not as much as before but not bound
either the lead over the 3080 is about
13 so not particularly worthwhile going
much above that at 1080p we still see
scaling links to our aggressive settings
for this one the 3090 TI fw3 ran at 161
FPS Average stock lowest paced as we'd
expect and well with the OC giving us
seven percent that's one of the best
gains from overclock and we'll see on
this card for the whole review it's not
particularly impressive but uh it's
better than what we saw elsewhere the
3090 filthy casual Edition wasn't much
behind here either in the division 2 at
4K we measured the RTX 3090 TI ftw3 at
133 FPS average with lows paced in
accordance with other frame Diamond
consistency pacing on this charge the
overclock boosted Us by five percent
consistent with previous result results
up to 140 FPS average compared to the
RTX 3090 master that we just re-ran
tonight the lead is about 16.5 percent
the 3080 TI still sits behind that with
the 3080 Eagle at 105 FPS average about
tied with the 6900 XT for reference the
39 DTI leads to 30 80 and 6900 XT by
about 27 in exchange for the massive
price increase again uh even at those
scalp prices gaming is best out on cards
at or below the level of a 3080 or 6800
XT which we're only really saying just
in case some of you are newer here and
haven't been in the market for this
cycle to know that at 1440p the RTX 39
TI fcw3 and the overclocked results
align with no difference as they bounce
off of other limitations the leadership
over the 3090 is reduced to nine percent
due to this limitation so there's not
much to learn here other than as we
already knew running at lower
resolutions and settings won't be
benefited by Extreme Graphics processing
capabilities at all now AMD has
maintained an advantage as the
resolution goes down to 1080 or 1440
price to price in the past and that's
true here as well if you remove the CPU
Bond the 6800 XT and the 3080 are in the
184 FPS average range and are more than
capable here with the 3090 TI leading by
19 as capped by other devices in the
system in Rainbow Six Siege the RTX 390
TI ftw3 ran about 239 FPS average and we
see there's still plenty of scaling Room
by The OC landed at 249 FPS average
that's a four percent uplift which still
doesn't feel particularly worth it for
the effort but considering the level
performance this car is already at 530
Watts there's not much more room without
just committing to competitive
overclocking the 3090 ftw3 allows the
3090 TI a lead of 12.3 percent about in
line with our previous results for
perspective the 3080 manages 80 percent
of the 3090 TI's performance in case
that's helpful in making your choices
later at 1440p the results boosted to
417 FPS average One stock or 430 over
clocked there's still sufficient room to
see scaling at 1440p with these graphic
settings as well the 39 ETI ended up
leading the 1600 XT by about 18 percent
with AMD gaining some ground as
resolution drops the 3090 Masters led by
about 10 percent in this one for one
last Benchmark we'll look at GTA 5 at 4K
really just for fun with our test
settings this old game remains
challenging for gpus to run at 4K the 39
DTI ftw3 capped out at 126 FPS average
again with good load timing while the OC
pushed 5.4 percent ahead the lead over
the slavin Lee 3090 non-ti poor people
Edition is about 10 percent once again
showing that the average Gap is
consistent across games okay so as noted
we were trying to sort of respect
everyone's time and just put it all up
in the front of the video you get the
idea uh the increase versus the 30 90 is
about 10 plus or minus a little bit
increase versus the 30 80 is sometimes
19 to 27 depending on the application of
the game
and 3080 6800 XT really just were just
re-emphasizing this point for people who
might be new to Building Systems new to
the market haven't been in the market
for a few years the maximum card you
need to be looking at for a gaming
computer really stops at a 30 80 or 6800
XT and our original reviews for those
largely stand the numbers have shuffled
a little bit with drivers but the
concepts are the same and when you would
buy each one Remains the Same so that's
where you need to stop looking if you're
buying for gaming for 30 90 type cards I
mean the 30 90 what it came out was an
absolute
mockery of a card it made a buffoon of
its Nvidia made a buffoon of itself by
doing the whole 8K gaming push doing 8K
sponsored content before the launch of
the card and trying to present it as if
that's even remotely realistic as a wide
sweeping thing it's just not don't
expect that that's stupid uh and we're
not there yet and that's fine
not many people have an 8K monitor or TV
or whatever so it's just a silly or
relevant marketing point but it's still
there on the slides as if Nvidia
couldn't be like reducing the focus to
zero percent isn't enough we need we
need to still look like we're committed
to this idea so let's do 30 focus on it
the rest was on content creation there's
some gaming discussion so it Stacks up
like this very simply the card as it is
from EVGA is well built it is at
atrocious price at 2200 but this is not
surprising to anybody the thing that is
a little more surprising is the power
consumption at 500 watts this changes
the landscape for the class of power
supply you have to buy at the high end
and more importantly transient load
spikes are a massive consideration for
the 30 series and they will be for the
40 series as well from what we're
hearing at least right now from the
power supply manufacturers and transient
load spikes is something we're actually
working on doing some testing with this
particular card but what you need to
know is that these are things that
sustain from actually something about
100 microseconds and it sounds really
short and it is except with a lot of
power supplies including some of C
Sonic's higher end units a lot of 850
watt gold units thousand watt gold units
a transient Spike of a couple X the
expected power consumption uh or even a
couple hundred Watts over not
necessarily full 2X or something that's
enough to where if the power supply
doesn't have enough capacitance to soak
the change you'd you lose power and the
system will shut down from functionally
an ocp or over current protection so
that's what you need to watch out for we
did not run into that issue with this
test setup we were using the EVGA T2
1600 watt though which is absurd I mean
that's a lot of capability from a power
supply so we're working on a follow-up
content piece to look at that this has
been an issue with the 30 series in the
past we haven't seen it yet on the 3090
TI because we've only had it for two
full days of testing and we didn't spend
any of that on transients so anyway
something for you to be aware of where
this is a gap in our testing coverage
that we are working on to fill in over
the next few days or a week or so uh so
we we can't include that in a conclusion
here ultimately then obviously like the
Titans have been for us in the past this
is largely I probably don't buy this we
do see the value in content creation
because we've used it that way as the
price hurts a lot
um if you're making money on it then
it's kind of like business class
internet where they say you could have
consumer internet actually you can't
because you're a business so you have to
pay business class rates get basically
uh the same thing that used to be
available for consumers but you pay a
lot more that's kind of where the 390 TI
slots in where if you're a professional
especially if you're making money it
starts to get easier to justify but it
still hurts in the pricing so for us a
hard pass on this 8 to 12 percent
for twenty two hundred dollars is insane
the only reason that cash grabs like
this and the 30 80 12 gigabyte can work
is because if you're new to the market
and they know this if you're coming to
the market and you need a video card and
you see the 3090 is out of stock
but the out of stock pricing says
whatever two thousand dollars which is
um the the current price Nineteen
Hundred twenty dollars is the price of
the evj FTW three to Thirty ninety you
see that and you see the new one for
2200 or something 300 difference you've
talked yourself into already two grand
so now you're like huh what's another
couple hundred dollars to just get
something and be done with this and
that's kind of the market we're in right
now everyone knows that we've said this
for many months at this point uh it is
getting boring from a Content
perspective but it Remains the reality
so we do want to put that out there but
the power is really we think the main
story here at the incredible 500 plus
watch so that's it for this one check
back for follow-ups as always again two
days with this full days
um we are exhausted and tired but we got
through the review I'd like to do a lot
more depth to it but that's the limit of
what we can do and still hit embargo
which we have a responsibility to do to
make sure people are informed as soon as
this thing goes up so
that's it for this one thanks for
watching and we'll see you all next time